this isn't a Jon Jones problem Jon Jones
has been ready to go wants to fight they
couldn't find him a fight they were
banking on Francis that's how they
thought the deals he had done they were
banking on Francis and didn't get done
so you have Cyril gone there waiting
in the shadows
um it's a great fight and we'll get into
that fight after this what's hilarious
to me is John's a plus 100 I would put
my entire life savings on Jon Jones
beating zero gun that's how confident I
am in that fight a plus 100 I know Vegas
wants the lines move my God I need to
bet on it as soon as I get out of here
to make a ton of money on that fight if
Francis on one leg can out grapple Cyril
gone over five rounds
what do you think John's gonna do